-Former President Donald Trump
praised Vladimir Putin's savvy
and genius
amid U.S. warnings
of an imminent
full-scale Russian invasion
of Ukraine,
and yet even as
he was doing that,
Republicans and right-wing
pundits claimed
it was President Biden
who was showing weakness.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
I do not profess to be
a foreign policy expert
by any stretch.
Most of my
foreign policy experience
comes from my magical
semester abroad in Rome
when I dodged
out-of-control Vespas
and fell in
with Dickie Greenleaf
and that creep Tom Ripley.
And, oh, wait, that's a movie.
I'm remembering a movie.
Anyway, I'm no
foreign policy expert,
but even I can see that
virtually no one in the world
thinks what Russia is doing
right now is a good idea --
apparently, not even
Putin's own advisers,
who looked frozen and terrified
during a bizarre
National Security meeting
broadcast on Russian television
earlier this week,
where Putin quizzed them
one by one
on what he should do as if he
didn't already know the answers.
-The National Security Council
of Russia had a televised event.
They broadcast this
highly choreographed session
of the Security Council
in Russia,
in which they were discussing
the possibility,
Vladimir Putin
and his top officials,
of recognizing those rebel
republics in the east of Ukraine
as independent states.
-This was when he was speaking
to his Security Council
before the actual address
to the nation, to be clear.
And according to
the Moscow bureau chief
of the "Financial Times,"
these are --
well, we know these the
senior-most Russian officials
over there sort of arrayed.
None of them were within
20 yards of Putin at any point.
-First of all, why is he sitting
so far away from them?
Did he put them there,
or did they all gradually
scoot their chairs back
during the meeting?
[ Russian accent ]
Yes, Mr. President,
in regards to Ukraine,
I believe best path forward,
and don't --
don't quote me on this,
because I would like very much
not to be wrong.
[ Normal voice ] Usually to see
people sit that far away,
a guy has to bring
a Komodo dragon onto the subway.
"Hey, don't worry, everybody,
he doesn't bite.
Ow! Bad timing, Gary."
This photo --
[ Laughter ]
This photo reminds me
of an interview Trump did
during the 2020 campaign
at the Lincoln Memorial
when the interviewers sat
like a mile away from him.
I guess they wanted
to be far enough away
so they could get up
and leave at any moment
without Trump noticing,
you know, just sneak off
during one of his insane rants.
[ As Trump ]
Lincoln, we love Lincoln.
Good old Abe.
"Abe" rhymes with "Gabe,"
which, of course,
reminds me of the great --
the great Gabe Kaplan.
He should -- He should really
have a statue, too,
if you ask me.
Welcome back, Kotter.
Kotter.
He left, but he came back.
He came back.
He came back and he whipped
those Sweathogs into shape.
Oh, we love the Sweathogs,
don't we, folks?
We love -- Folks?
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] I'm pretty sure
that once Trump got rolling,
even Lincoln scooched
his chair back a little.
[ Rumbling ]
[ Laughter ]
Really good.
Guys, this is the first time
we see the graphics, too, so...
If a single tear
rolls down my face,
just know it's 'cause
I'm really [bleep] proud
of what they did today.
Also, check out this close-up
of Putin's advisers.
Yikes!
They look like they're all
in the waiting room
for a colonoscopy.
You know things are bleak
when even Putin's closest
and most loyal advisers don't
want to look him in the eye.
That's the way my staff
looks at me when I say,
"I think I might do my
Al Pacino impression tonight.
What do you think, Mikhail?
Mikhail?
Should I do the Pacino?
Barb?
Barb, you're looking
like you think
the Pacino might
be a good idea."
Yeah, but you know what?
Maybe it won't work.
I mean, because tonight's
"Closer Look" is about --
[ As Pacino ] Ukraine.
Our crane.
This whole courtroom is crane.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
See, the audience loves it.
How about you, Lincoln?
You love it, right?
[ Rumbling ]
[ Laughter ]
And just to give you an idea
of how nervous and reticent
even Putin's closest advisers
have been to agree with him,
at one point, Putin demanded
that the director of Russia's
Foreign Intelligence Service
give an opinion
about whether Putin
should recognize
two breakaway regions of Ukraine
as independent territories,
which, of course, he later did.
Here's how that exchange went,
according to a reporter
for the "Financial Times."
Putin said, "Speak clearly,
do you support recognition?"
And the adviser said, "I will."
To which Putin replied,
"You will or you do?"
Then the adviser said,
"I support bringing them
into Russia."
To which Putin replied, "That's
not what we are discussing.
Do you support
recognizing independence?"
And then the adviser,
flustered, said, "Yes."
Jesus!
I have flop sweat
just from reading that exchange.
Usually you got to dangle
a guy over a shark tank
to get that tense
a back-and-forth.
And, Vlad, the last thing
I want to do
is give you management notes,
but the way you say things
like "speak clearly"
almost guarantees
that people won't.
[ Laughter ]
Hoo-ah!
So look, if their body language
and tentative responses
are any indication,
not even Putin's
closest advisers
thought this was
an especially smart move.
Virtually no one does.
The entire world is aghast
and horrified.
The only people
who could possibly think
this is a good move are those
unemployed fringe weirdos
who go on
small-time radio shows.
You know, like this guy.
No, you don't got to say that.
I mean, well,
maybe you got to say that
so someone will pick you up
at the Moscow airport
when you flee our jurisdiction.
It's just insane that Trump
is still so desperate
to praise a bloodthirsty tyrant
like Putin every chance he get.
Trump narrates Putin's
every move like he's Tony Romo
calling the last drive
of a playoff game.
"Oh, man, here he comes.
He's setting up
at the goal line.
And he's going to roll tanks
into the end zone.
You got to say, Jim,
this is very savvy."
Also, can we go back
to the beginning of that clip?
Oh, there was a TV screen
in a room you went into.
I guarantee you there's not
a room in that man's life
where there isn't a TV screen.
Even his sauna has a TV
with a squeegee next to it
to wipe off the condensation.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] Sean Hannity's
sweating again.
Oh, okay, okay.
[ Normal voice ] So Putin's
own advisers look scared.
Meanwhile, Trump's watching
Russian tanks roll into Ukraine
with pom-poms in his hands,
calling it genius.
And in that story,
who did he say the words
"this is genius" to, anyway?
Was Melania
in the room with him?
[ As Trump ] Mel?
Mel, you got to come see --
Vlad's inva--
It's genius, Mel.
Mel? Mel.
Oh, wait a minute.
This is just a scarecrow
with a dress on it.
Well played, Mel.
[ Normal voice ] So the leader
of the Republican Party
is calling lawless
Russian military aggression
toward a sovereign country
genius,
while President Biden is trying
to unite world allies
to stop Russia
and making it clear he does
not want a war with Russia.
-Who in the Lord's name does
Putin think gives him the right
to declare new
so-called countries
on territory that belong
to his neighbors?
This is a flagrant violation
of international law
and demands a firm response from
the international community.
Let me be clear.
These are totally defensive
moves on our part.
We have no intention
of fighting Russia.
-First of all, I'm glad
he said that last part,
since no one serious
seems to want
or is suggesting a war
with Russia,
which would be catastrophic,
which is why the world
needs to do everything possible
to avoid one.
Second, I like when Biden
goes full Scranton
and uses old-timey phrases
like "who in the Lord's name?"
Biden's got the tone
of a guidance counselor
sitting backwards on a chair,
trying to talk a burnout kid
into turning his life around.
[ As Biden ] So you think you're
some hotshot, huh, chief?
Recognizing breakaway regions,
invading your neighbors.
Who in the Lord's name
do you think you are?
Guess what -- You're not
going cruisin' tonight,
'cause you're in detention
with the rest of the Sweathogs.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
And yet in comparing those two
reactions from Trump and Biden,
Republicans apparently come to
the obviously insane conclusion
that it was Biden who was
somehow projecting weakness,
although Biden's critics
on the right
can't seem to make up
their minds
about whether we should be
showing strength toward Putin
or whether we should just
be siding with Putin.
-The administration,
basically on the Obama model,
is for weakness.
They avoid war, frankly,
by accepting surrender
of their own interests.
-The GOP House conference
tweeted a picture of Biden
walking away from the podium
with this quote --
"This is what weakness
on the world stage looks like."
-The administration
has been so muddled
in the way they have
made Vladimir Putin
have the upper hand
throughout this entire time.
-The White House,
it seems like the response,
even though it was supposed to
be quite robust, was very timid.
-He looks very weak, and Russia
is taking advantage of it.
-It might be worth
asking yourself,
since it is getting
pretty serious,
"What is this really about?
Why do I hate Putin so much?
Has Putin ever called me
a racist?
Has he threatened to get me
fired for disagreeing with him?
Has he shipped
every middle-class job
in my town to Russia?
Did he manufacture
a worldwide pandemic
that wrecked my business and
kept me indoors for two years?
Is he teaching my children to
embrace racial discrimination?
Is he making fentanyl?
Is he trying
to snuff out Christianity?
Does he eat dogs?"
-Why? Why do I hate Putin
so much?
Did he call me a racist?
Did he get me fired from my job?
Did he ring my doorbell
and run away,
leaving a flaming paper bag
on my doorstep?
A bag I then stomped on,
only to discover it was filled
with dog feces?
Did he make plans with me
as means of an apology
for the dog [bleep] prank
to meet at a fancy restaurant
and then not show up on time,
texting every five minutes,
"On way, there soon,"
only to arrive an hour late and
then say, "I had a late lunch.
Is it cool
if I just watch you eat?"
And then when my food did come,
would he pick it off my plate,
one French fry at a time,
until he'd eaten at least
half of the French fries?
And when the bill
came from the waiter,
did he point at me and say,
"I actually didn't eat"?
Even though both the waiter
and I
could see the giant
ketchup smudge on his face
from the colossal bite
he took of my burger?
Did Vladimir Putin
do that to me?
Yes, he did.
[ Laughter ]
He did it yesterday.
Also, to all those warmongers,
like Mike Pompeo
and Newt Gingrich
and the House Republicans
who called Biden weak,
your dude is the one
who just called Putin savvy
and praised his genius.
Do you guys even pay attention
to what Trump is saying anymore?
Or do you just assume,
like most of us,
that he got lost
wandering around the 18th hole
at one of his golf courses and
now he just lives in a sand trap
with a bunch of pigeons?
And even when he was president,
Trump was always so desperate
to buddy up with Putin,
even Putin couldn't believe it.
Trump was like those
rookie defensive backs
who would stop Tom Brady
after the game for an autograph.
"Hey, I know I'm on
the other team, but huge fan.
Don't tell my coach."
Putin always had
that smile on his face
when he was next to Trump like,
"I can't believe
how easy this is."
And as much as I don't
want to hear
from the Trumps
and Fox Newses of the world,
I very much also
don't want to hear
from the same
belligerent maniacs
who have consistently been wrong
about foreign policy
for decades,
like former Trump
national security adviser
and Bush administration
official John Bolton,
one of the key cheerleaders
of the Iraq war
who has advocated for bombing
or invading multiple countries.
For some reason, Bolton was
invited on MSNBC yesterday
to give his take
on the Russia situation.
-How do you deter
Vladimir Putin?
He seems absolutely determined
to do what he is about to do,
because he's amassed this force.
Do you see him backing down?
-I don't at this point.
Look, the President
announced on Friday
that his policy had failed.
He said, unequivocally,
the Russian decision
to invade Ukraine had been made.
That's an admission
that deterrence has failed.
-I'm sorry, but there's no one
I would rather hear from
on foreign policy
less than John Bolton.
I'm all for having experts
on cable news,
but you don't get
to be an expert
if you've never been right.
Bolton was wrong on Iraq,
wrong on Afghanistan,
wrong on the mustaches
coming back.
Although I did
meet John Bolton once,
and he told me
my Pacino impression is great.
Oh [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
That means it sucks, right?
The leader
of the Republican Party
praised a bloodthirsty autocrat
as the U.S. warns of an imminent
full-scale invasion
that virtually the entire world
is horrified by.
And yet the GOP has the gall
to call Biden weak.
Maybe Trump
is just praising Putin
in the hope that if he runs
again in 2024, Putin will say...
-♪ Welcome back ♪
[ Laughter ]
-So I think in order
for that to work,
everybody here would have --
in the body
of the "Closer Look,"
they would have had to leave and
go watch "Welcome Back, Kotter."
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings over
2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.